i'm with the catholics
good morning and welcome to this live
stream from the european parliament here
in brussels and we're very well welcomed
especially to those who are joining us
on
almost all the social media channels of
the parliament uh today is the
international day against homophobia
biphobia transphobia and interphobia
and we are going to discuss today with
my guests
the progress made so far in the eu and
the current challenges i'm joined
for this discussion by the president of
the european parliament roberta mitzola
and two
members who co-chair the parliament
group on that monitors the eu lgbtiq
actions mark angel and terry reinke
welcome
thank you for the invitation if you want
to be part of this
discussion you only have to put your
comment or questions in the comments
section and i'll put as many as i can to
my guest president mitzola
what did in your opinion are the most
pressing issues today when it comes to
lgbtiq rights in the eu
well i think this parliament has stood
for a very long time in pushing
against resistance in a number of
countries for progress
of equality
and this is the day
every year i say i wish we don't have to
have a day where we need to remind
everyone where
we still lag behind
but the european parliament and the
european union you can say is a beacon
for where those rights have
seen the biggest leap both in terms of
legislative changes but also in terms of
societal changes we are still
very far away but at least we can
very much with colleagues and it's a
real honor for me to be with terry and
with and with with mark in order to push
a little bit for better equality uh and
recognition and understanding of
people's wish to live in the world as
they want to live striper on instagram
is asking uh what can what is the
parliament doing can you mention a few
uh legislative actions that the
parliament has taken recently to
to to
to combat these forms of discrimination
well we can make a distinction between
the political actions so for example
some ones of symbolism today for the
first time
um on all our offices across the world
in all the member states but also here
in strasbourg and
in luxembourg we are flying uh the flag
on all our buildings and we have also
taken the decision that this will happen
automatically every year without a
specific decision to be taken
secondly
we have a number of internal decisions
whereby as an institution we still need
to do much more in order to to help um
rainbow families grow with their with
the children
and and how they uh they need to to
receive the same rights as anybody else
irrespective of their marital
status or gender status at home
so a lot of work is being done in that
regard and we have very very good
staff organizations but also members
that push for more rights and then of
course we are always the first
institution to condemn
attacks uh in in in other countries but
also in member states and
you cannot imagine how often we find
ourselves together and say we have the
perfect laws on paper but still people
are are being attacked in schools they
are being bullied they are being
isolated and there isn't enough training
education but also let's say push back
against any attempts to sideline or
segregate and isolate and that i think
is where the european parliament needs
to push much more
and i'm looking forward to the next two
years and maybe when we meet again
in one year's time and look at what the
intergroup which is a group that brings
members together from all political
groups as to where we have arrived and
where we still have to go
uh mr angel do we have a reason to
celebrate
one more reason to celebrate this year
what are what progress has been made in
and combating hate and discrimination
against the lgbtiq community we have a
reason to celebrate but we also have a
reason to be sad because there is
backlashes in some countries but today i
want to be positive and i want to say
that in the european parliament we have
had 91 resolutions since the beginning
of the mandatory where uh
which were specific lgbti or where there
was some uh articles uh concerning lgbti
people so we've been very active and i
think that is a reason to celebrate this
active european parliament when it comes
in in defending uh lgbti reds and when
it comes to protecting algebra rights we
also are very happy that this commission
now has for the first time a
commissioner for equality and this is
important too and the commission
president is also very much committed
mrs
ozil avondale for a union of equality
and the parliament is a strong ally to
the commission in realizing this
union of equality and i think we should
celebrate that but not forget that there
is backlashes not forget that there is
haste speeds not forget that there is a
strong anti-gender movement who wants to
bring us back into patriarchy who is
attacking not only lgbti rights but also
women's rights and i think therefore we
have to be strong and celebrate today
you mentioned women's rights as well the
intersectional approach to this to lgbt
rights how important is this
and how important is it to address it
also when it comes to legislations and
actions
i think for the european parliament and
i think inside of the intergroup where
we are working across border and also
across member state we now have members
from from all member states of the
european union and an intersectional
approach is very important to us because
we see that the attacks that mark and
roberta were already speaking about um
are also coming towards different groups
and that they're trying to really roll
back on rights that have been fought for
and that have already been acquired
in a lot of ways so
we try to really counter that together
and to obviously stand up for lgbti
rights
to mention the strategy for example
where we are going to push for
recognition of parenthood all across the
european union between member states and
we are looking forward to
adding hate crimes to the list of eu
crimes which i think will be a very
important step to safeguard our
community
and but we also look beyond that and how
we can work to fight against racism how
we can work to uh promote the rights of
people with disabilities and i mean
always if you talk about these groups
there is an overlap because there are
you know um people from the lgbti
community who are facing racism people
from the lgbti community um who have
disabilities and we are trying to really
see that together to to have a full
picture and then to horizontally fight
against all forms of discrimination
because we want to live at the end of
the day in societies in the european
union where everybody can live freely
and free from discrimination and free
from violence and yet
we
we see the numbers according to this
report
this survey is pretty old because it's
like almost three years old but still in
2009 in the european agency uh union
agency for fundamental rights found the
discrimination on grounds of sexual
orientation gender identity expression
and sex characteristics was actually
increasing 43 compared to
to 37 in 2012. how do you interpret
these figures how do you as a politician
see do you
do you see
that there is a regress in this uh sense
i think i would interpret it in that way
that yes there is regression we see very
aggressive and systematic campaigns
against the lgbti community and i have
to mention poland and hungary as the two
i think worst examples but certainly
there are problems in all eu member
states and we see that the lgbti
community is being scapegoat for
societal problems and that there is this
kind of narrative that we are a threat
to society and i think we have to very
firmly stand against that but i would
also say that when we look at for
example the fraud survey that we can see
that maybe also issues that were already
there before are coming more to the
surface because we talk about the issues
more and also people feel that they can
speak about discriminations that they
are encountering that they can report it
to the police and i think that is why
it's important to stand firmly against
any kind of queerphobia but at the same
time also to really highlight these
issues because only when we address them
we can actually raise awareness around
them and then change society for the
better
can i jump in here because of what terry
says is is really important about
when you collect data where it comes
from and how many
uh citizens of the eu let's focus on on
the european union people who live in
our countries actually report incidents
that are committed against them we have
seen an increase
in some countries but in others because
of
of let's say
societal
being
led by governments that are allowed to
push it down to for for example for
reports not to be made in order to to
disincentivize the possibility for you
to say this is not okay
for parents to be able to tell you
listen be careful now because this is
coming and in this in this country and
if i can look back uh to countries like
mine that join the european union with
that hope of protection for all rights
for everyone then what we are also
seeing is that countries that once they
enter the eu they think that nobody is
going to keep check on them nobody is
going to control what's happening and
you can backslide as terry mentioned
in specific countries and we are seeing
this across the board so what we i think
have to do as a european parliament
first of all is to be
not only the promoter but the reminder
that those rights exist
encourage reporting but also in this
building for example if something
happens you are going to be protected
and it is not always obvious that that
is the case and that is known to be the
case
and you all mentioned the discrimination
i hate speech but this sometimes uh uh
president mitzola is coming from
politician uh it does uh
somehow fuel this sort of hate crimes so
uh what are the dangers of this rhetoric
you think yeah we see it we see it
everywhere in this house in all
countries and that is a very dangerous
and increasing
i don't even want to call it phenomenon
but increasing fact uh what we have done
however uh in this parliament is
establish a very let's say constructive
pro-european uh center of the house
let's call it that whereby we can fight
against that because if we don't it is
so easy to use populist narrative that
verges on hatred to have that hatred
pass by because we think it's going to
go away if we don't fight if we try to
not to do anything about it and for many
years we actually looked away or allowed
too much to be said when it was
unacceptable for it to be said and if
you if we look at for example what has
happened very difficult to two years
within because of the covet pandemic and
we are now seeing an increase of cases
because of society's reopening people
meeting together and therefore
attacks increasing we have seen that
coming coming our way in all cities
across the european union what we have
seen in this house is that where there
were attempts
to create so-called lgbtiq free zones uh
something i didn't know existed as a
word when i stood up and said look you
know for me this is not something that
can be acceptable uh in in the european
union and we were joined by colleagues
from
most groups
in this in this house and it is that
constructive core that needs to push
back against increase of of of attacks
speeches and it is our responsibility
especially as elected representatives
not to let that easy populism take hold
especially when looking in the next two
years when we are going to start
preparing for our elections in 2024 and
we all have that responsibility no one
can exonerate himself or herself from it
uh you mentioned uh yes they saw the the
infringement procedures that the the the
hate speech that has been going on in
some countries especially the hungary
and poland where there were concrete
attacks on the lgbtiq community um
is
uh what so the commission also launched
the infringement procedure is this
enough and what else can be done uh mr
angel to to to ensure equal treatment of
the lgbtiq community
for people no matter where they live in
the eu well first of all it took the
commission a long time to to to get into
infringement procedures for poland and
hungary and we end the party but we're
really pushing that there there's also
a suivee that they will that there is a
follow-up of that and uh they can count
on us that we we will because we have
been in contact with activists in poland
and hungary we've visited poland and
hungary and we see the situation there
and these people there they believe in
europe they believe in our values they
believe in the european union so we
cannot disappoint them so really i hope
that these infringement procedures will
come to a positive end at uh
um
well that's but um but uh i just wanted
to come back to what uh roberta said
before this uh parliament we have so
many allies this resolution when we
declared the european union as an lgbti
freedom zone was voted by
498 members of this parliament out of
705 and that made me proud as a gay man
it made me proud that we have allies
that that my rights are respected by my
colleagues and this is i think was a
very strong message also to the to the
uh our friends in poland and in hungary
that they know there is a strong group
in brussels the european parliament
stands for your rights
um
here in the eu uh
we pride ourselves so uh or when it
comes to anti-discrimination laws for
against the lgbtqiq community
but as member states have different
legislations when it comes to to free
movement of families for example uh it
is often difficult for these rainbow
families to to move from one country
to another and exercise their treaty
rights for instance uh i mentioned here
the case of bulgaria there was an ecj uh
ruling on that uh how what can we do to
defend the free rights of movement or
the the their treaty rights actually for
couples for rainbow couples who find
themselves in difficulties and sometimes
their children's risk being becomes
stateless
and can i first start by saying you're
right that the european union has come a
long way in terms of anti-discrimination
policies and especially coming from a
conservative member state like germany
germany wouldn't be where it is today
and fighting discrimination if it wasn't
for the european union i think that has
to be said but at the same time we also
have the horizontal equality directive
that has been blocked now for many many
years in council which would actually be
the next step in really providing
protection from discrimination on all
grounds of discrimination in all sectors
of our society so to really fulfill that
promise of the european union to protect
people from discrimination we really
urgently need to to add that to the list
of policies that we have but you're
absolutely right we have a very specific
challenge for rainbow families and i
mentioned already in the strategy and
there is a very positive proposal and
that the member states are supposed to
recognize parenthood so for example
birth certificates adoption certificates
between each other so that we don't
create a situation where a family just
exercising their right to freedom of
movement moves from i don't know finland
to poland and then maybe loses their
legal status towards towards each other
and so we really want to make sure um
that this changes but i if i may add um
the intergroup in the european
parliament would also like to extend
this not only to parenthood but also to
partnership because we believe obviously
there is a very specific protection
needed for children but we also don't
want for example couples who are married
in one member state to move somewhere
and then not be married anymore in that
other member state so i think that there
is um still a lot of work to do to to
make sure that all people in the
european union including rainbow
families can really fully exercise their
right to freedom of movement as eu
citizens if i could come in here please
the petition committee of this
parliament has been very active on the
free movement of rainbow families and we
have this fantastic european parliament
research service which made a fantastic
research document of about 100 pages on
the free move on the barriers to free
movement of rainbow families so and then
we voted a resolution again which had a
good majority here where we we we asked
for for this directive and the
commission has promised it so uh
the the the the parliament is really
also defending uh the rainbow families
i i can maybe draw parallels with what
happened
over 10 years ago in this in a not a
similar but on the way i remember one of
the
the very first report i i
had to shadow in this house was ulrike
lunachex report in 2013 which was a road
map against homophobia
it was difficult to get that through
with the majorities that we wanted to
have and if you compare the wording
how much let's say less ambitious it was
because that was the maximum that the
parliament could achieve which led to
then the commission coming back as mark
mentioned earlier you know with the
current program with a commissioner
dedicated
to equality and helena works works very
well
and very much in that regard
in but if i also look back from a legal
perspective so i talk as a lawyer now
we have been struggling uh in the
european parliament for example and we
did that for years to recognize divorce
judgments from one country to another
that took almost 10 years to achieve
maintenance in other words when you
divorce who pays for children
which of the spouses would pay for the
children if they move country and that
is fundamentally what we have said as eu
member states that what the judge in
luxembourg gives us a decision a judge
in malta needs to execute doesn't always
happen and that is not possible as you
mentioned it's not a treaty right but
it's a it's a regulation right in other
words there are regulations that oblige
member states to do that and if you
think about who is suffering you have
people who simply want to have their
union recognized uh from one country to
another to have access to social
services to health to education to as we
have we have seen in in a pandemic we
had a lot of cases of families that were
got stuck in countries where their
rights and their status was not
recognized we are in 2022 i think we can
really for uh
finally say that if there is one country
in the european union we share the
values we push for that same principles
same fundamental rights they have to be
recognized elsewhere and enforced more
importantly because also as as terry
said it's not always about the children
who have a right to the family life that
they enjoy in the country where they
were born or where they are being
brought up but also with people who have
chosen a union that is recognized and
legalized in one country that has to be
recognized by another no excuses it's
not possible to accept that
and uh
one of the commission's lgbt equality
strategy one of the main pillars in is
the used role in the in the world and
the promotion of human rights in your
opinion do you think safeguarding the
human rights and lgbt rights in
particular should be at the heart of use
extraordinary policy this is something
that is at the core of our external
policy and in fact uh i spend a lot of
my time meeting with representatives
from from countries and in outside the
european union where of course the
recognition and the rights and the
protection is is far behind what the
european union has done and in fact that
is why it is so important when we talk
about the european union as being a safe
shelter for persons who are escaping
persecution and member states because of
their sexual orientation this afternoon
in fact i will have a a meeting with a
ugandan lgbtiq activist who is going to
send that message that the european
union needs to continue to be uh that
beacon of the world that protects and
shelters that's why also we push in our
trade policy in our trade policy for
very strong human rights uh chapters and
even now we have a we are working on a
modernization of a trade uh um agreement
with chile where we have even a gender
chapter in it and i think that's the
future to also put that in our trade
policy
because uh uh
we cannot tolerate that there is
countries where where lgbti people are
are persecuted even uh you know that
there is still countries where there's a
death sentence
for same-sex relations
and can i add that especially yeah i
just said that you have been very vocal
also when it comes to to to non-new
countries like turkey and other balkan
countries is it also important to to to
to make sure that these uh rules these
this uh the rights and fundamental
rights of people are safeguarded when it
comes to to also
dealing and negotiating with potential
candidate countries to the eu absolutely
i think that um the safeguarding of
fundamental rights rule of law democracy
has to be a priority also in accession
negotiations and i think that we have
come a long way there as well because i
think it didn't used to be a priority as
it is now because i feel that now when
we speak for example about the accession
of countries from the western balkans
when we speak about our relationship
with turkey and this has become much
more of a topic that is being discussed
i i still think we can you know listen
even more to the activists on the ground
specifically because in the integra we
are always working obviously we do
parliamentary work but what is also
important for us is really to include
the community in every single decision
that is taken because at the end of the
day the people from the lgbti community
know best what they need and so i think
that there we can even do better
especially when we talk about accession
um but if i can just add the thought and
i think that this is also true for
accession the western bargains turkey
now ukraine and when we look at the
world you know we see that this um this
struggle between democratic societies
and autocracy you know authoritarian
rule regimes and that this is really
sort of
fueling especially now with the war in
ukraine where russia an autocratic state
has um has attacked a democracy and i
think that when we talk about what makes
democracies what you know what is kind
of the core of democracies it is also
next to obviously having democratic
elections having a system based on rule
of law it is also the safeguarding of
fundamental rights for all people in
society so i think especially in this
sort of world situation that we are in
right now or better spoke about the eu
being a safe haven for lgbti people but
i also think a beacon of hope that we
live in societies where this struggle
for fundamental rights for democracy for
rule of law um uh is working where we
are moving forward where we make
progress i think a lot of people in the
world look at the european union and say
it's working there and this also gives
us hope that we can move forward with
this and so i think that this makes our
work inside of the european union but
also outside in the external relation
regarding lgbt lgbti rights even more
important
thank you
mr angel we have a question from
instagram from sam who says has you made
any progress in combating hate and
discrimination against uh uh
lgbtiq community then how can we educate
how can do you help to educate uh people
on lgbtiq issues to make this society
our societies more inclusive well
progress certainly we have done it we've
talked about the progress and when it
comes to education i think is and this
is something we as a parliament also
defended in many resolutions it's very
important that in schools in all the
member states we have comprehensive uh
sexual and relationship education not
only sexual education in the way how to
do not become pregnant or to become
pregnant but the whole the whole
relationship around it and comprehensive
sexual education means also talking
about
a trans identity about gender identity
about intersex people so to inform
informing is is is very important and
from every age at this education has to
be age adapted and this makes
young people also much more resilient
against the tax it it helps
building up prejudice
and i think this is this is very
important that it starts in school very
early educating uh that that lgbti
rights are human rights women's rights
are human rights and and and not
tolerate that uh some political leaders
with hate speech try to divide the
societies but bring societies together
you know fighting for lgbti rights it's
not that we're fighting for extra rights
it's just fighting
for non-discrimination fighting to have
the same rights as every other rights
and obligations as any other eu citizens
that's what is the fight for lgbti
rights
how important is it to have
representation not only in politics but
also in art media and etc in
institutions
how important is it so that we can give
a message to young people out there that
uh it is possible that
their freedoms are safeguarded
representation of activism or
representation in terms of having lgbtiq
politicians who are more active in
politics but also not only also in other
uh i have met so many uh
politicians from my country and in other
countries
who are part of the lgbti community who
tell you i can't say
i can't say
because i would not get elected or
i can't say because i will be only
identified with that
as that
and that has made me think quite a lot
in terms of how we balance between
the fights that you fight and how you
are as terry said the beacon of hope
because we can do it uh because we are
uh we have seen how what we say what we
do what we decide in terms of laws that
we adopt it actually makes a difference
in people's lives i uh i have four boys
i would like that all the teachers in my
that teach my children uh actually tell
them and educate them uh and so that
they are let's say aware of what
they need
or how they need to be or how to but to
be honest when i had this conversation
with them it's almost like ma well of
course these are obvious
these are obvious like why are you even
asking us this and and perhaps we have
to and i have to learn
that when compared to when i went to
school and we had to learn certain
things for our children growing up today
but again in european schools where the
discussion is there it's present and
it's even let's say not a concern
because it's taken for granted in terms
of openness in terms of not even
bringing it into the conversation so i
think it's a little bit of both that we
need to make sure that you have the
protection you have the awareness you
have the education and the training um
for for the let's say the societies that
are growing up not to have to ask the
questions or wonder whether they need to
fight for something more is that enough
of course not and as we heard earlier i
mean we have regression we have
backsliding but we can also celebrate
the fact that for uh younger generations
this is something that they expect from
their politicians they expect from their
teachers from their activists in order
to say look yes this is something that
that we can all agree on far away but i
think we can manage
uh terenke you
are very engaged in activism on lgbtiq
issues you identify as a member of the
community how important is this to you
and how do you see this progress as
politician does this help you in your
in your politics she's the best she's
the
clear no no best no but you know when
when roberta was talking about this like
uh i i used to be in a secret
relationship and because my partner did
not want to come out that was a very
very difficult experience for me and
then when i when i started to be in a
relationship with my wonderful
girlfriend
we talked about it and i think we also
jointly and very deliberately agreed
that we want to be
visual that we want to be visible in
society with who we are that we are in a
in a lesbian relationship with each
other because i think that at the end of
the day when then you know you have
people who are so obviously part of the
community um it also becomes something
um that is much more just accepted that
you know people don't even think about
or talk about or make an issue about so
much anymore so i felt that um this was
something um that would help
to to just speak about it to make people
see that this is a completely normal way
of having a family life um and i still
hope i know that yesterday um i think
second league a football player came a
17 year old
second league football player i came out
in the uk and which i only have a lot of
admiration for um because i think
especially for male football players it
is still a very big challenge to
overcome
and i think we have to show this
admiration we have to show the support
because this really takes courage
and then i hope that not only in
politics but as you say in arts in
academia in sports everywhere because
lgbti people are everywhere we are part
of this society and um that's why i also
think that we should be visible
everywhere where we are um and yeah in
politics in in sports and wherever it's
needed and i hope with that actually
then maybe in a couple of years we don't
even have to talk about it so much
anymore we don't need an either hobbit
specifically anymore because it's just
so accepted in society um that that we
don't oh we can raise our rainbow flags
every day
i'm very confident that they will arrive
that because young people are so open
they for them it's not a problem and
coming out maybe in a few years nobody
has to come out just live your life you
know
do you know what's going to be my
question for how long do we still need
to do this
well i hope not for that long because
i'm i'm very confident in the use and
now with the conference in the future of
europe i met so many young people and
these parliament engaged in so in
bringing so many young people together
and when i address this the subject of
lgbti rights it's such a normality for
them and as i said i hope that in a few
years nobody has to come out you just
live your life do you know any straight
uh teenager 16 going to his parents and
telling or her parents and telling hey
mommy i have to tell you something i'm
heterosexual or i you know and this
would be the ideal that just live your
life you have a boyfriend and people say
okay he's gay you have a girlfriend
there's a woman lesbian if you're trans
non-binary just live your life and then
i'm sure that
in in in decades to come if we fight
this anti-gender movement and we don't
we push them back then
this will happen and people can live the
way they want without
being discriminated that's what we are
fighting for
absolutely we're reaching the end of
this discussion but i want a short
message from all of you uh regarding
ukraine it had the war in ukraine has
driven so many women especially and
lgbtiq people across the border
especially trans women and men to
hungary poland and other eu countries
whose identity may not be recognized in
these countries so uh what in your view
should member states eu
states do to protect
their rights
well for me i
think that we should be quite concerned
about what we are hearing about reports
of trafficking of women
in many countries uh ukrainian women and
girls so this is something that we are
pushing now the also the the commission
to to look at the legislation and see
whether that can be a specific
framework of protection we see it every
time
there is an influx of members from a
third country we saw it in 2015 with the
influx from syria and we are seeing it
again now i think our message has to be
consistent europe has
opened uh its its heart and its homes
for uh ukrainian um elderly people
persons with a disability women and
children i saw them myself
when i when i went there and i think the
rights that they are afforded should be
the same like every other citizen of the
european union and everyone else living
in the european union should be afforded
and that means that if we need to
protect them and call out where
discrimination is taking place we should
do it no matter where the tap is
and again our fantastic european
parliament research service has done a
study on uh on the effects of lgbti
people the consequences in the of the
ukraine war and
there's a few problems first of all we
know that uh trans women with gender
with male gender marker in their
passports they're not allowed to leave
ukraine that's already a huge problem
and those who can leave there is
problems with hormonal treatments we
have to
ensure that they have access to health
and uh some countries do not provide
them this hormonal treatment so here
civil society ill guy europe was very
active in in doing this but this is
something we have to ensure we also know
that ukraine is is the country with one
of the highest hiv prevalence in the
european union and they're now getting
treatment and i've been in uh i've been
an activist in an ambassador for unaids
and i know how important it is and we
have to support also ukraine to send
medical to send treatments because they
have been
supply chain uh supply chain uh
disruptions so we have to support the
people who stayed in the ukraine but
also those who who managed to flee that
they get their treatments uh be it hiv
treatment for those who are infected
with hiv be it for trans persons who are
in transition or intersex person who
need hormones and it's very important to
ensure that and
and
that's
something uh i'm very happy that uh the
activists europe elder europe and others
are are really active on on it
uh can i just so can i just because i
completely agree with everything that
you said and i think specifically also
not looking at the large number of
refugees coming from ukraine but maybe
it's also a good reminder that in
general the eu's refugees policy needs
very very urgent reform because we were
speaking a lot about fundamental rights
and the fundamental rights of a lot of
refugees trying to find shelter inside
of the european union at the external
borders are really being we say in
german kicked with the foot so um we
really need to work on this and i hope
that now with the situation that we have
with the great challenge that we have
that maybe there is also going to be
movement we know that certain member
states have blocked progress in this
field we really urgently need to work on
what we have um and i hope that with
this situation now we can actually bring
some dynamic into this discussion in one
very short question your message to the
lgbtiq community out there
be who you are love who you love be
proud of all your colors and we are
going to support you
we as a european parliament are here to
be your beacon of hope and we will not
let you down
you're welcome in the european union
thank you very much for this discussion
i really appreciate it and enjoyed it i
will finish this uh um this uh live
stream with a comment from one of our
viewers from youtube cosmane if i'm not
wrong no one should be disadvantaged
because of their gender
all people are weak equal and everyone
should be given the same chance thank
you very much for following this
discussion and see you soon in future
live streams
thank you robert thank you
you